>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
FOR MONTHS NOW PRIVATELY, WE'VE
BEEN SEARCHING FOR A MEANINGFUL
DEFINITION OF THE WORD "EQUITY."
WE'VE TALK TO LINGUISTS, SCOURED
THE FOURTH CORNERS OF GOD'S OWN
INTERNET TO SEE WHAT EQUITY IS.
WE'VE DONE THIS NOT FOR
PLEASURE.
WE HAVE HOBBIES BUT BECAUSE WE
FEEL IT'S OUR DUTY AS A NEWS
PROGRAM.
EQUITY IS THE ORGANIZING
PRINCIPLE OF THE UNITED STATES.
ON THE DAY HE WAS INAUGURATED,
JOE BIDEN SIGNED EXECUTIVE ORDER
1395 THAT MAKES EQUITY MANDATED
ACROSS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
STRANGELY NEITHER JOE BIDEN OR
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS EVER DEFINED
THE WORD.
SO WHAT IS EQUITY?
TONIGHT FINALLY WE KNOW WHAT IT
IS.
EQUITY TURNS OUT IS RACISM.
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
EQUITY IS RACISM.
TO BE CLEAR, WE DON'T MEAN
RACISM IN THE SINCE THAT ICE
CREAM AND SHAKESPEARE AND MATH
ARE SUPPOSEDLY RACIST OR THAT
DR. SUESS IS NOW CONSIDERED A
CYCLOPS IN THE KU KLUX KLAN,
WE'RE NOT TALKING AND THE ILHAN
OMAR DEFINITION OF RACISM.
NO.
WE MEAN RACISM IN THE LITERAL
SENSE, IN THE WAY THAT MARTIN
LUTHER KING DEFINED THE TERM,
WHICH IS THE ACT OF HURTING SOME
PEOPLE AND HELPING OTHERS ON
THEIR RACE.
BIGOTRY, PREJUDICE, HATRED.
THAT'S WHAT EQUITY IS.
WE KNOW THIS THANKS TO LORI
LIGHTFOOT, MAYOR OF CHICAGO.
SHE SAID EQUITY AND INCLUSION
ARE THE NORTH STARS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION, LIGHTFOOT
EXPLAINED.
THEN SHE GOT SPECIFIC "ON THE
OCCASION OF THE TWO-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF MY INAUGURATION
OF THIS GREAT CITY,LY PROVIDE
EXCLUSIVELY ONE-ON-ONE
INTERVIEWS WITH JOURNALISTS OF
COLOR.
SO IN EQUITY, SHE'S REFUSING TO
GRANT INTERVIEWS TO LIGHTFOOT TO
WHITE PEOPLE.
SHE SAID MANY PEOPLE ARE
TALENTAND HARD WORKING BUT
UNFORTUNATELY AS SHE SAID "WHITE
NONETHELESS."
SO THERE IT IS.
PLAINLY AS ANYONE HAS EVER SAID
IT OUT LOUD.
WHITE PEOPLE ARE DISQUALIFIED
BECAUSE THEY'RE WHITE.
NOT BECAUSE OF ANYTHING THEY
DONE OR SAID OR THINK.
LORI LIGHTFOOT DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THAT.
SHE'S NOT INTERESTED IN WHAT
THESE WHITE PEOPLE MIGHT BE LIKE
AS INDIVIDUALS OR PEOPLE.
SHE DOESN'T CARE WHAT KIND OF
WHITE THEY ARE.
ANCESTORS COULD BE FROM ITALY OR
FINLAND OR SPAIN.
THEY COULD BE MEMBERS OF THE
BRITISH ROYAL FAMILY.
COULD BE PENNILESS IMMIGRANTS ON
A BOX ON A SIDEWALK ON MICHIGAN
AVENUE.
RICH OR POOR, DOESN'T MATTER TO
LORI LIGHTFOOT.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS THEY'RE
WHITE.
ALL WHITE PEOPLE ARE THE SAME.
THEY'RE DEFINED BY THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN.
YOU CAN SEE HOW THIS MAKES LIFE
EASIER FOR LORI LIGHTFOOT.
SHE KNOW WHOSE TO HATE BY
LOOKING AT THEM.
IF SOME DAY THE CHICAGO POLICE
ROUND UP THE ENTIRE POPULATION
OF THE CITY, LORI LIGHTFOOT
WOULD HAVE NO TROUBLE PULLING
THE RIGHT ONES OUT OF LINE FOR
PUNISHMENT.
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING, THAT
WAS A NAZI REFERENCE.
IT WAS DESERVED.
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS A MONSTER.
ANY SOCIETY THAT ALLOWS
POLITICIANS TO TALK LIKE THIS
HAS AN UGLY FUTURE AHEAD.
VERY UGLY.
OF COURSE, NOBODY SAID ANYTHING
ABOUT WHAT SHE SAID IN HER
MANIFESTO.
EVEN CHICAGO REPORTERS, SOME OF
WHOM CAN NO LONGER DO THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE OF HOW THEY WERE BORN
AROUND UP TEPID COMPLAINTS.
LISTEN TO THIS PERSON FROM NBC.
>> ANOTHER REPORTER CALLED AND
SAID, I'M HEARING THEY'RE ONLY
TALKING TO BLACK OR BROWN
JOURNALISTS.
WHAT?
THIS DOESN'T SOUND REAL.
SO I REACHED OUT TO THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR.
SHE TEXTED ME BACK AND SAID
YEAH, THAT'S TRUE.
SHE SAID NO, WHITE REPORTERS
HAVE BEEN IN THE ROOM FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THE YEAR.
IT'S TIME TO HEAR FROM OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: WHAT?
IS THIS REAL?
WHAT YOU HEARD IS CONFUSION AND
NOT OUTRIDGE.
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS A DANGEROUS
BIGOT.
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS HURTING OTHER
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE.
THAT'S THE CRIME.
IT'S THE ONE THING THAT NOBODY
WANTS TO SAY OUT LOUD.
HERE'S THE RESPONSE FROM A
REPORTER AT THE CHICAGO TRIBUNE.
"I'M A LATINO REPORTER WHOSE
PRESENCE WAS REQUESTED TODAY.
SHE SAID WE RESPECTFULLY
CANCELLED."
POLITICIANS DON'T GET TO CHOOSE
WHO COVER THEM.
TALK ABOUT MISSING POINT
COMPLETELY.
OF COURSE POLITICIANS CAN CHOOSE
WHO THEY TALK TO.
ALL OF US HAVE THAT RIGHT, THANK
GOD.
WHAT POLITICIANS CANNOT DO UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCE IS ATTACK AN
ENTIRE GROUP OF CITIZENS ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR SKIN COLOR.
THAT IS RACISM.
IT IS IMMORAL, IT IS ILLEGAL
UNDER COUNTLESS STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS.
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO ALLOW
BEHAVIOR LIKE THAT FROM OUR
GOVERNMENT.
WE'RE ALL EQUAL IN THE EYES OF
THE LAW.
WE'RE ALL CITIZENS.
WE'VE GOT AN ENTIRE GRANITE
MONUMENT ON THE NATIONAL MALL IN
WASHINGTON PROMISES THAT WE
WON'T BEHAVE THAT WAY AGAIN.
WE WILL NEVER ALLOW IT.
BECAUSE WE'VE EMBRACED EQUITY,
WE'RE NOT ALLOWING IT, WE'RE
ENCOURAGING IT.
MEANWHILE, HOW IS CHICAGO?
THE CITY OF CHICAGO IS CRUMBLING
UNDER LORI LIGHTFOOT.
MURDERS JUMPED TO 50%.
HUNDREDS MORE DEAD, MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE, CHILDREN, MOST OF THEM
BLACK.
IS THAT SOCIAL JUSTICE?
NO, IT'S NOT.
IT'S NO ONE'S DEFINITION OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
LORI LIGHTFOOT DOESN'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
THERE'S 50 MEMBERS OF THE CITY
COUNCIL IN CHICAGO.
THEY'RE CALLED ALDERMEN.
ONE HAS PRESSED LORI LIGHTFOOT
TO EXPLAIN WHAT SHE'S DOING TO
THE CITY.
RAYMOND LOPEZ IS A DEMOCRAT.
HE REPRESENTS THE 15th WORD,
WHICH IS OVERWHELMINGLY
NONWHITE.
RAYMOND LOPEZ CARES ABOUT HIS
CONSTITUENTS SO IN JANUARY HE
RAISED AN OBVIOUS POINT WITH THE
MAYOR.
MAYBE CRIME IS SHOOTING UP IN
CHICAGO BECAUSE CHICAGO IS A
SANCTUARY CITY, NOT ENFORCING
FEDERAL LAW.
HOW DID LORI LIGHTFOOT RESPOND
TO THIS?
SHE'S CALLED HIM A RACIST.
>> BEING AN IMMIGRANT OR REFUGEE
IS NOT A CRIME.
ALDERMAN LOPEZ AND NAPOLITANO,
SHANE ON YOU.
SPIRITED DEBATE AT THE HEART OF
OUR DEMOCRACY IS NOT THE SAME AS
USING RACIST TROPES AND
XENOPHOBIC RHETORIC TO PROMOTE
YOURSELF ON THE BACKS OF OTHERS
AND DEMONIZE THEM